Many years ago you've been quiet. I mean,
nah, I don't know, friendly, but do you know Donald Trump? Uh, and you've,
you've said some nice things about him. Uh, is that something you,
you regret or do you, do you stand by that?
Uh, set me up with a saw then, but not what I see now. Uh,
unfortunately, uh, he has misused his talents.
He's a very talented man.
Welcome. Welcome to Stockholm and welcome to this. I'm nervous.
[inaudible] so, but it's, eh, I mean, you're,
you're famous as a people person. What, what, what would you say is, is, um,
the best way to connect with people?
Be authentic, uh, care, uh, to be,
to be genuine. People care that you know,
but they will know that you care a lot of people know,
but they don't seem to care and something like Karen connects.
Do do you, when, when you,
when you S w w when you give a speech and you've given a lot of famous
speeches, do you do improvise a lot,
or do you write them before you.
Often, often I write them, but it's according to the occasion sometimes,
uh, speeches as be expressed.
If they're read just like kissing through a telephone something's missing.
But when, when you get a thought here, uh,
when she wants to know something, when she wants to learn something,
she can Google,
but you grew up in absolute poverty and you grew up in a time without the
internet. How did you, how did you learn things?
How did you find out about the world?
Well, by the experience, um, uh,
got on the bus with my mother and I had to go to the back of the bus. Uh, I, uh,
wanted to sit up front so I could see with other children, the white children,
and they were told to stay, and I had to leave. Then my mother, Penn,
Smithfield humiliated. One of my father's friends said to me, don't cry.
She's she?
She pinched you because she loves you and you teach your children to adjust so
they won't get hurt. They won't, they won't be violated. So that,
that was an experience. Another experience.
I came home from college and I had those speeds of 25 annotated,
bibliographies, and, uh, w the color lab where they didn't have enough books.
So she told me go to the other, the central library,
her friend was the librarian, and I rushed down.
And two police happened to me with a two police.
And I gave him the sheet. I expected you. They're going to get the books.
You said in seven,
no one was in the library with me. And, uh, I had to get back to school earlier.
And I said, well, let me go downstairs. I'll get that conducted myself.
She said, no. And the police said, you're here, but she say it.
I walked out in the back end. I cried. I was hurt,
humiliated violated.
And that summer seven classmates,
we were arrested trying to use the public library.
That was a real experience. Later on, we did, we saved building elaborate.
You don't have to move with you this. And we'd be, we began the process. Uh,
and that process led us to, uh,
we ended up going to Washington when Dr. King gave the speech that I have a
dream speech. And most of us were there had the, uh,
the honor of having men jailed.
And I became free of jails and death at that time.
And what most people don't realize the context of that speech,
the day he gave that speech from Texas across the floor left to
Maryland. We couldn't use a single public toilet in the state Capitol.
The day he gave this speech,
we couldn't buy ice cream in holiday at Howard Johnson,
we couldn't buy
[inaudible] was counterfeited black and Latino soldiers had to sit behind
Knott's appeal debits in American military basis.
We lived under the degradation of apartheid. So it was,
I didn't have to Google as it was, I was living it.
And we use a lot of word of mouth at that time,
as opposed to the scientific process that we have that,
but we had our own way of I'm going to,
we'll be kind of the cities that were most depressive. Uh,
we chose to go to them to try to open up the doors.
[Inaudible], what's your strongest memory of poverty.
It's a song has been repotted is in the winter time when it's real cold.
And my father put up wallpaper,
not for decoration with the breakthrough win and had to sleep
on the, on the cop and my brother.
So we could feel each other and stay warm at night. That's poverty.
Uh, my father going to the grocery store with my father on the weekend.
He could count, but not the fractions.
So like I've had six eggs for a dollar and then 12 eggs for a dollar,
that type thing. Uh, we would be searching to get groceries. And he said,
I have $9 to get roasted with this week.
And we went over like nine 30 to nine 25.
We had to figure out what to put back in line with other people looking at us.
I mean, the idea that you go between the 5 cents or 50 cents,
because you misread, or they, uh, some calculus of sorts that's poverty.
And yet.
Poverty, maybe the after some money, but spirit is the presence of faith.
And faith must be stronger than you than your predicament. You have to,
we never saw ourselves as poor. We just didn't have enough money, enough money,
and the will to fight back is an enriching experience.
And that's what it is because you were born in the slum does not mean Islam was
born in you.
You have to have the power within somebody within must say that you
deserve dignity.
What do you want to describe as is, I mean, a lot of humiliating experiences.
Do you think that they fueled your activism, that they have been important for,
for you being an activist your whole life?
Well, my life's predicament put them in, in that situation. I mean,
if someone is some point in life, you'll find what's fulfilling for you.
What matters to you? Uh,
caring for people matters more to me than, than money. For example,
that the King was a, you must be materialistic than minded, man.
That's the materialistic in numbers, serials to do the stuff you need to do,
but not caught up in law. The frivolous stuff.
Is this what you would tell a young activist? Like [inaudible],
she she's just started her struggle.
W when you are blessed with the sensitive that she has you search for your
environment, for example,
if she were to come to American Dayton and she was a black child,
and she's on the front of the bus, that doesn't,
that doesn't require her resistance goes it's, the Victor has been one,
but climate change is real.
So you have to search for the issue of your time. Immigration is a real issue.
Gender inequality is a real issue. So that, that, that stuff to fight,
to give them a sense of that. You matter.
Um,
[inaudible] we got to talk about Dr. King. Um, he,
you were here in Stockholm to celebrate him.
You were invited by then the Nobel museum. Uh,
he would have turned 90 this week.
January 15, 19.
And, um, I wonder what is in your view,
uh, having known him so well, w what is the greatest misconception about,
about Martin Luther King?
It may be how academic in doubt he was,
because he was such a people person. He didn't wear it like a professor per se.
He finished high school at 15.
If you went to college at 19 in seminary at 22 infants PhD at
26, extremely bright guy,
but he also had a vision. We think you're just the deal.
He thought the vision, if you have a thousand people and all of them are blind,
the one that person's in charge. So vision is the deal, not just unity,
you know.
Uh, I, I am, when, when Dr. King was killed, I was,
I think, two years old. And you're, I mean, do you,
do you learn about Martin Luther King at all, yet in school?
Yes, actually today we watched his speech.
I have a dream on English class today. Yes,
[inaudible].
He was 90 yesterday. Yeah.
I still that dream levels. Well,
actually we see the dream being realized, uh,
it, it's not a simple dream. It sometime it seems the walls move for the back,
but the dream of that day was overcome the, the, uh,
indignant indignities I've been in that public combinations.
Then we got the right to vote and then he was killed.
And the dream little beyond the grave,
April 4th is on the back. And they in Memphis,
dead on the balcony for the later Barack,
when the back of the white house,
we gone from the white house in the back of the Memphis,
but all that sadness for the years in the wilderness for the years of struggling
and building coalitions.
You were there that day 51 years ago when he was shocked. Um,
can you, can you take us back to what you remember.
Day before we sat in the room preparing to March and
a very happy day it's seen next day,
we had more or less the same drill, having fun.
And I had a group down from Chicago. We were, they were playing music.
I was coming across the courtyard. It was,
was for them left at five o'clock. We left. It was around six o'clock.
And he said, uh, uh, just, you're always late.
I said, doc, as you've all just said,
you don't even have on a tire and we're going to Reverend Kyle. So for dinner,
I said, not the prerequisite eating, there's not a Tyson appetite.
And we laughed. And by the Powell, he hit him right here.
He asked a friend in the car with my favorite song, that precious Lord.
And he raised his head and wouldn't hit him. He never, nobody.
What hit him really? I miss him very much. I miss him very much.
Many years ago. You've been quiet. I mean,
I don't know friendly, but do you know Donald Trump? Uh, and you've,
you've said some nice things about him. Uh, is that something you,
you regret or do you, do you stand by that? I said what.
I saw then, but not what I see now. Uh,
unfortunately, uh, he has misused his talents.
He's a very talented man,
but somehow he is determined the blood wouldn't go to his base.
You become president of the whole nation becomes your base.
So he sees the world through a keyhole and not to adore the leaders that the
best minister of the world through a door,
that was a very special genes about the King. He saw the world.
So do it. If he was in Stockholm, uh, Sudan and Mississippi,
he was at home because in this world are no more foreign. As we're all family,
different languages have been one message of hope, healing and love.
[Inaudible]. I wondered you, you try to, to become a precedent, uh,
presidential candidate twice. Uh,
but you've also been close to so many precedents.
Do you sometimes feel the relief that you never got that far?
No.
[inaudible].
I'll tell you what. When I was in resurrection center with Dr. King,
after he was killed, the King was dead and Robert Kennedy's day,
we were depressed. So one morning a group of people that came in the rain,
looking to me to give them something. I'll say something.
I had no money to give them. I couldn't get them back home.
I looked at faces and I said, you still have earth. You'll you're hungry,
but you're God's child and say, I am somebody.
And then they begin to respond. I am somebody. He came out. For example,
repeat, say, I am.
Well, I am setting up Stan, Stan, Stan,
myself.
I am somebody.
I am somebody respect me,
protect me. Look me red and yellow,
Brown, black, and white. We're all precious in God's sight.
I am. Somebody's your screen.
Thank you so much. I
hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.